MAX SALTONSTALL: Hi,
I'm Max Saltonstall,
and today I'm going to talk
through some simple things you
can do to secure your
workloads and sensitive data
in the cloud, while
still keeping it private.
We're going to talk
about how shielded
VMs and confidential VMs
can help you do this.
Let's start with creating a
shielded VM in the Google Cloud
console.
Shielded VMs are virtual
machine instances
that are hardened with a set
of easily configurable security
features to ensure that
when your VM boots,
it's running a verified
bootloader and kernel.
Using shielded VMs
helps protect workloads
from threats, like remote
attacks, privilege escalation,
and malicious insiders.
And yes, everything
we do here could also
be done through G Cloud
and the command line.
Starting at Compute
Engine, to to VM instances
and then Create.
Give it a name, then go down
to Boot Disk and click Change.
Choose any image.
They're all shielded by default.
Close that window with Select
at the bottom, and then go
down to the tabs labeled
Management security disks, et
cetera, and click Security.
You can see the default
shielded VM settings.
Let's enable Secure Boot
here for extra protection,
and then click
Create to spin it up.
Turning on Secure Boot
gives us added protection
from boot and kernel
level malware.
Once it's ready,
click on the new VM
and click on Stackdriver Logging
under Logs on the Detail page.
At the Logs page, you can filter
for just VM integrity logs
by clicking on the
All Logs dropdown,
and choosing shielded underscore
VM underscore integrity.
Now you can see
just the shielded VM
offense for this instance.
Let's dig in further.
Click into the log for
Early Boot Report Event.
Then expand the JSON payload,
then the Early Boot Report
Event inside that.
You can confirm the
VM's integrity state
from the early boot perspective
from the line showing
policy evaluation past is true.
Early Boot encompasses
firmware and other drivers
loaded during the boot
process of the VM.
Back to the logs list,
open up the log that
starts with boot counter,
then expand JSON payload,
then Late Boot
Report Event shows
you details about the integrity
of the rest of your kernel
drivers.
Once again, you can confirm
the boot integrity of the VM
from the line Policy
Evaluation Past being true.
That shows that the VM
passed all late boot checks,
and is running what we expect it
to be running, no shenanigans.
Now head into Cloud Shell
to disable Secure Boot so we
can test this integrity check.
Uh-oh.
First, stop the VM with G Cloud.
Next, disable Secure Boot
using G Cloud Update.
Now restart the VM, and
you can see in the console
that the integrity verification
has failed by examining
the same logs as before.
Finally, make a new integrity
baseline with G Cloud
so you can compare
future measurements
against the current state.
Pretend that you already
triaged this failure,
and consider it acceptable.
With this new
baseline established,
go check the integrity
state of the shielded VM
again in Stackdriver Logging.
Make sure you click Load Newer
Logs to get the latest results.
Looking at the late
boot report event again,
we can see that the policy
evaluation passed is true
once again, showing that
we have met our integrity
standards, the ones we
just lowered, of course.
Finally, time to look at
these metrics over time
via monitoring.
Open up monitoring, and
head to Metrics Explorer.
Under Find resource,
type, and metric,
choose the resource GCE VM
Instance and the metric Early
Boot validation.
Then add a second metric,
Late Boot validation.
We've got our graph, though
it's going to make more
sense as a stacked bar graph.
Looks great.
Now you can keep track
of your integrity
over time with gorgeous colors.
When our customers are ready
to move their workloads
to the cloud, one of
the biggest challenges
is securely processing
sensitive data in the cloud
while keeping it private.
Google Cloud offers solutions
to securely bring sensitive data
to the cloud, using
encryption to protect data
in transit for offline
or online ingestion.
But when we have to
actually use the data,
it's much tougher to
keep it encrypted.
With confidential
computing now in beta,
Google Cloud lets you
take data security
a step further by
encrypting data
while it's being processed
in a Google data center.
Confidential
computing environments
can now enable
encrypted data to be
processed in memory
without exposing it
to the rest of the system.
And this can be done
without the need
to make any changes in
your workload or code.
Let's take a look at
the product by making
a new confidential computing
VM which contains a shielded
VM to perform the computation.
Inside Compute Engine,
create a new VM instance.
Enable Confidential Computing
service with a checkbox.
Note what changes are being made
to your VMs with this setting,
then click Enable.
You can run any
workload you want.
Your VM is now
much safer and more
secure with all of
the memory encrypted,
so your data is safe in use.
But what about instance
templates and groups,
you might ask?
Well, we've got you covered.
The same confidential
computing option
is available for
instance templates,
and you can either use
one of our premade images
or your own custom image
that best fits your workload.
Now my template defines a
shielded confidential VM setup,
and I can go to instance groups
to make a managed instance
group with that template.
Beep, bop, boop, we're done,
with a set of instances auto
scaling for my needs,
secure and ready to work.
Confidential
computing environments
can now enable
encrypted data to be
processed in memory
without exposing it
to the rest of the system.
And this can be done
without the need
to make any changes
in your applications.
Thanks for joining me today.
Enjoy shielded VMs and
confidential computing
for your workloads on cloud,
and check out the link below
to get started.
[MUSIC PLAYING]